bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
cazzo dimenticato la musica è da tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono qua vj oggi siamo in un nuovo logo
prima di cominciare ragazzi cose bisogna
partire per la panarda settimana mi sta
inquietando questa cosa con la fama da
settimana che questa settimana è stata
vinta da mike come cazzo
mai y fatto regala ragazzi a livello di
originalità è il più bel disegno che
abbiamo cioè l'urlo che sarebbe questo
originale per questo è molto più secchi
ma veramente tanto quindi grazie mike
per il disegno della madonna e dire che
possiamo passare alle news
vuoi dirle tu le news zio le faccio dire
a lui ragazzi se non c'è quasi niente
oggi cosa veramente tanto strana ma mica
roba che tra poco vado in sicilia 15
star ora in circa cinque giorni anche un
po per vacanza un po perché devo fare
due raduni che tra l'altro non vedo
l'ora di fare ma nel frattempo usciranno
video come se fosse a casa quindi non
preoccupato è una roba che è successa
ragazzi che praticamente ho trovato un
dvd di quando ero piccolo avevamo girato
a scuola io la scuola avevo fatto un
film tra virgolette una roba avessi
malori trovato nella cantina della
cantina delle cantine tipo quindi voglio
assolutamente vedere che ho paura come
avevo recitato avevo tipo dieci anni non
so che cazzo posso uscire fuori però va
beh non mi ricordo che lo stesso dio
sarà degno dei film di moccia ragazzi io
mi sto vergognando così eccolo eccolo il
gran figo ma qualche roba quasi cazzo di
pantaloni mi metteva a mia madre ma poi
cristo la musica della pausini ma che
problemi avevamo a quei tempi ragazzi
eccolo lo trovate o mio dio che che cosa
addio il cazzo sto facendo con quel
fiore
ma non m'ama perdona nei por mi vida
loca perché sto stuprando un fiore come
se non ci fosse un domani dorato che un
fiore fosse caldoro della profezia
davvero non capisco perché c'era in
passato anche bello è che lo sto guarda
il tipo michia stanotte da coltello 9
hacker triste che pantaloni avevo ma
gesuita sorella non mi interessa
dopotutto ben cinque anni più di lei
5 adesso cinque anni possono non
sembrare anche ma vedrà fra qualche
tempo cioè un no non sto guardando se mi
stanno dando indicazioni sto
semplicemente guardando l'arcobaleno è
una tristezza le mani addosso zio che
cazzo fai che cosa lo guardi così
denuncia la malizia guarda il suo
sguardo assassino che ti vuole ucci
teatro in questa cosa che cioè i capelli
me l'ero fatta fare perché sembrava figo
andiamo avanti ragazze quando lei aveva
95 anni io ne avrò ben 100 marchio a
[__] sai fare le addizioni zio
complimenti forse c'era una slide finale
dove c'ero anch'io da ecco il bello
siano bello ma gesù santo chicca per
tutti fuori tutti le mani e le mutande
che siete tutti arrapati lo so le canne
pesanti zio signore e signori gain
terapie o meno il livello di recitazione
mio è comunque quello è stato veramente
tragico ragazzi lasciamo perdere ai
continui abili con questi ragazzi quando
tipo combattuto contro quel ragno quella
volta questa settimana è successa la
stessa [__] cosa con lo stesso
[__] ragno di prima sì ma perché
ragazzi ma perché ma perché ma perché
cazzo vuole della mia ma perché perché
perché ricetta per chi è cristo vuole la
mia vita sto nerd alibi di coso che non
è morto disabile quale da anni io io io
no io non ce la posso piu fare a viverlo
solo di ragni non ce la posso fare
uccidere mi fanno schifo quanto è grosso
gesù mi fa veramente schifo reni favera
mi fa vomitare il cazzo mi fa schifo
cristo perché non esistere queste merde
un crepaccio sardo morto è morto non
ancora lì è morto è morto si muove porca
[__] [__]
guarda io non lo butterò mai cioè rimane
lì finché non viene assorbito da gesù
non fate commenti su quello che avete
appena visto per caso mi stesse
chiedendo una cosa del tipo ma favi una
volta che l'hai ucciso come l'hai
buttato fuori questa è la risposta e ci
resterà per molto tempo finché non
cambio caso questo passiamo al fari
risponde che bello prima domanda arriva
da marty gamescom e cazzeggio time
guardati cioè chiamo ho sputato come
cazzeggio thain guardati becchiamo
refrain che vita in realtà ragazzino
veramente mai visto cerchiamo essere
cavit lo posso non è amore come accedi
per confermare la tua età sono
maggiorenne risiamo ragazzi perfetto
sono un bambino di nove rende sempre
amato psych prego uscire che ogni sera
prima di andare a dormire a casa un
marziano dell'opel come cresciuto c'era
il rumore ho detto cioè che rita ceca
vita che poi va dal e sentendomi il
primato finocchio pazza più mandato via
dicendo gli stronzi metterà uno schiaffo
del mio mandato ho letto che adesso sto
piangendo una lacrima strappa storia
ho sentito un rumore alle mie spalle
dello slam tra se mi toccano mai
sferrato con i supporti moon i dati però
va che cosa ma serio sono pronto serie
allargato le minchiate per cipro faccia
è penetrato va in gol molto male non
faccio perché oggi volato le sue
penetrazioni ma devo farlo godere un
alto con il suo forte ruggito quando è
riempito il mio culo con il sogno ma vi
risponde risponde in diretta ad un
messaggio d'amore di una tua fan a caso
il club è nei messaggi a cazzo su fei
facciano anche uno nuovo tra vincolo tip
piccolo ti prego rispondimi
non chiedo altro piccolo piccolo ho
capito cosa intendere che affermi un
attimo piccolo piccolo era piccola di
dragon fly junior sarebbe junior che
anche detto piccolo quindi pacchiarelli
gnocchi faris quando indossa una gonna
e fai vedere come sei sex va bene
e vero che tu sia contenta perché ti ci
sia masturbata sopra quindi ragazzi
direi che possono includere qui il blog
ma prima di concludere devo farvi una
domanda molto importante la fare domanda
di oggi e siccome lo spot del fai
ventilatore a punto un casino di
successo inventatevi un qualcosa sulla
quale io possa fare uno spot è l'idea
più bella ragazzi la farò come spot nel
prossimo video quindi ragazzi spero che
il video vi sia piaciuto concludo quel
blog
i miei capelli stanno chiedendo pietanze
il video è piaciuto e calciato momento
mi piace è già facilità ai giocatori a
tale si chiama spaccato tutto sei siti
si replichi mi davano prossimo video
bella ragazza